président mes chers collègues je
voudrais partager avec vous mon
incompréhension et ma colère face à
l'annoncé très médiatisée de la
proposition de loi d'une députée
écologiste qui veut interdire le gavage
des oies des canards pour la production
de foie gras interdire le gavage et dont
la production de foie gras dans notre
pays c'est une pure folie
le foie gras je rappelle représente
trente mille emplois directs
cent mille emplois indirects le solde du
commerce extérieur dans ce domaine et de
plus de 57 millions d'euros dans une
balance commerciale qui nous savons tous
est largement déficitaire
nous sommes dans ce domaine le numéro un
de la production mondiale
un exemple assez rare pour être souligné
et bien au delà de ces chiffres la
filière foie gras est représentative
d'un véritable savoir faire français et
en symbole fort de notre identité
si nous mettons le doigt dans cet
engrenage ce n'est pas seulement la
filière foie gras que nous pourrons
enterré mais bien toutes les filières
d'élevage la défense de l'animal si
elles deviennent sectaires et
dogmatiques ramener notre culture à sa
perte
alors à cause des abus de certains
industriels vous condamner l'ensemble
des petites exploitations familiales
dans notre territoire
or ces éleveurs aiment leur métier
élabore un produit de qualité dans des
conditions sanitaires exemplaires il
travaille dur chaque jour et participe
directement au rayonnement de la france
dans le monde
une fois l'ensemble des petites
exploitations enterré que ferons nous
mais surtout que nous restera-t-il une
agriculture industrielle aseptisé et qui
sera à terme délocaliser
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les députés en pleine crise de
la grippe aviaire au regard des mesures
sanitaires catastrophiques qui sont
imposés à la filière 4 nar il nous
appartient plutôt de venir en aide aux
producteurs et non de multiplier les
effets d'annoncé mortifère à coups de
vedettes américaines
merci là par l'état ne tienne stéphane
le foll milices de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire de la forêt sur des
buts et je ne crois pas qu et de
questions c'était une déclaration qui a
été faite pour défendre la filière foie
gras de france j'ai eu l'occasion juste
au début de cette séance de m'exprimer
sur le sujet le gouvernement a pris des
décisions face à un problème sanitaire
majeure et je les dis ces décisions sont
jamais facile à prendre parce que on
mesure parfaitement les conséquences que
cela peut avoir
je le rappelle face à cette situation
sanitaire une influence ya aviaire
toutes les exploitations sont concernés
et toutes les exploitations seront aidés
parce que c'est ça qui est l'enjeu
et c'est ça qui doit être mis en oeuvre
et je rends rencontrerait les
professionnels la semaine prochaine pour
caler avec eux les dispositions qui
seront mises en oeuvre pour ce qui est
du débat
s'il vous ayez du débat j'ai
parfaitement compris je me suis exprimé
de manière très claire pour dire que le
gouvernement allait était à côté de
cette filière avicole et en particulier
de tous les producteurs de foie gras de
france et de navarre
merci monsieur le ministre pour ses
producteurs
la parole est un monsieur gérard
charasse